next time they shine your light in the
sky don't go to it but that is dead well
here I am
be their hero Clark be their monument be
anything they need you to be or be none
of it you don't know as a swirl last
thing you never did
now we will battle
to the death
stay down I wanted it you be dead
already
you're not break
hey youtubers is Charlie the wait is
over [ __ ] is going down this week some
of you are probably seeing the movie as
we speak please do not spoil it for the
rest of us so what I'm gonna do is a
breakdown of all the fights that Batman
and Superman have had in the comics
including the Frank Miller stuff which
is technically off in its own universe
it's not canon to the main comics they
fought at least nine times I'm not
including Justice League dark side war
because you could look at that as like a
Batman V Superman situation but but not
in the literal sense as these other
examples are so here we go first time
JLA number 44 back in 2000 Batman really
paranoid keeps files on all of the big
Justice League members what their
weaknesses are what all their secrets
are those get stolen for the purposes of
taking down Superman the actual plan to
take down Superman doesn't really work
quite as well as the bad guys hope it
did fight number two Batman number 612
Superman gets mind-controlled by poison
ivy attacks Batman Batman has to put
Lois Lane in danger to snap Superman out
of it fight number three Adventures of
Superman number 642 Maxwell Lord mind
control Superman to beat the [ __ ] at a
Batman fight number four Superman Batman
number 33 Batman gets mind-controlled by
aliens Superman has to pretend like he's
ready to kill him in order to stop the
fight fight number five this is actually
the first one of the new 52 Justice
League number two Batman Superman
totally distrust each other they come to
blows but Batman is able to stop it once
he explains to Superman what his
intentions are they actually kind of did
a version of this in the animated DC
movie Justice League war where Batman
and Superman aren't super friendly the
first time that they meet fight number 6
Batman The Dark Knight number 5
Scarecrow doses Batman with his fear
toxin he goes after Superman who takes
him down like a sack of potatoes
Batman recovers fight number 7 Batman
number 36 Superman gets affected with
the Joker toxin goes after Batman who
takes him down with kryptonite isn't it
funny how you see them flipping the
script from fight to fight like one gets
mind-controlled then in the next fight
the other guy gets mind-controlled then
somebody gets dosed with the toxin then
in the next fight the other guy gets
dosed with a toxin fights number 8 & 9
are from the Frank Miller stuff so we
have the
Hartnell returns we're Batman an old
Batman goes after Superman who he thinks
has become a tool of the fascist
government the next fight number nine is
just the sequel comic to that Dark
Knight Returns - and there is a Dark
Knight three so they might actually end
up fighting again but it doesn't seem
like it's gonna go down that way and
they haven't finished the run so that
could be fight number ten if you guys
know about any other actual fights like
fist fights that Batman and Superman
have gotten to in the comics just write
them below in the comments I really just
tried to look at the times where they
were actually throwing fists at each
other and usually Batman's solution is
kryptonite because Superman as strong as
he is is very susceptible to mind
control and magic that is why Batman
typically carries that kryptonite ring
around on his utility belt it's not like
he keeps it locked up in a safe he keeps
it on his person just in case because
Batman is one of those characters that's
run every possible scenario and amongst
all the Justice League members he is the
cynic Superman is both the metaphorical
and literal source of Hope in the
Justice League Batman is the guy who
feels like eventually something is gonna
turn and things are gonna go to [ __ ] so
he's gonna be prepared in related news
of you guys didn't see it I am doing a
DC giveaway for two imax tickets for
Batman V Superman what's gonna happen is
there's a new episode of the flash this
week the giveaway will end whenever I
post that video so I'll announce the
winner in that video and they have been
posting a whole bunch of stuff so I'll
do new flash video sometime later
tonight but I'm also doing a new Gotham
video the Gotham video will post to my
Facebook page it's just
facebook.com/blackdogeducation you can
click here for my Captain America Civil
War post-credit video thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight